Steven twitch boss laid to rest in a
private funeral
ET can confirm the burial took place in
Los Angeles on Wednesday I
Sawyer's husband in the entire world
only close family was in attendance
including his wife Allison holker their
three children Maddox Isaiah and Wesley
and twitch's Mom Connie just like family
man like honestly they're my favorite
they're my favorite people you know what
I mean I never take for granted the
moments that I can make my mom proud and
while Wednesday's funeral was an
intimate one et's also learned a larger
celebration of life will be put together
soon I'm so grateful that I've had
Stephen part of my life it's been nearly
one month since twitch was found dead
from a self-inflicted gunshot wound and
now a source tells E.T how Allison is
holding up and keeping his memory alive
for their kids all of them are different
and all of them have no problem
commanding a room even our little
one-year-old like you know we love the
Full House our store says it's been a
very difficult time but Allison's always
been a strong person quote she is trying
to keep her composure and not break down
in front of her kids through this
process for their sake
adding that she's prioritizing their
mental well-being quote Allison is
making sure that all the kids know how
much their daddy loves them that he is
still with them and his spirit is still
flourishing that this has nothing to do
with them and that they can do things to
help keep his Spirit Alive I'm still in
a lot of shock
um my daughter
with Wesley his daughter and our kids
went to school together and he and I
went to college together and um
yeah it's a lot so since the news of
twitch's death many of his friends have
mourned the sad loss he's such a talent
and
warm wonderful heart and yeah he will be
he will be greatly missed including
Ellen DeGeneres who twitch worked with
for eight years as a DJ on her show he
was pure light if you knew him you knew
that if you didn't know him you saw it
and the dancing Community too I think
anyone who's ever met twitch will say
that he is the nicest most caring most
you know present person and and really
wants to make everyone feel better
Steven twitch was such a significant
part of the dance Community but then he
had this amazing ability to go way
beyond that and he just lit up every
room and he was so positive he has had
definitely a profound impact on me
um I just thought he was an angel my
heart goes out to Allison and the kids
and to his whole family and I just can't
imagine what they're going through
according to our source Allison has been
getting lots of support and an
outpouring of Love since her husband's
death quote everyone has really come
together to congregate around her and
her kids
foreign